[Music]
hi my name is Susan Dumais I'm the
assistant director of Microsoft's
a iLab and I'm here today with Michael
Jordan who is one of the world-renowned
computer scientists and statisticians in
the world
he's been at Microsoft earlier today as
part of our faculty summit whose topic
this year is systems and the future
disruptions that will be enabled by
progress and systems one of the topics
obviously in thinking about the next
generation of systems is where AI meets
system so we there have been sessions on
AI for systems and systems for AI and
Mike has been incredibly involved in
some of those discussions so I want to
Michael is pay Hong Chen distinguished
professor in EE and CS at Berkeley he's
also on the faculty in the Statistics
Department and part of a couple of
really interesting multidisciplinary
labs one on algorithms machinist and
people and the other on was bears
Berkeley AI research or something like
that Michael has a background in
psychology statistics and cognitive
science so he brings a really broad
perspective two problems one of the
things that I think is most impressive
like about your background is that
you've won a tremendous number of
publications tremendous influence in the
areas of computer science and statistics
but your awards come from a broad set of
organizations and fields you clearly are
a fellow of the ACM but you're also a
fellow of the American Statistical
Association the cognitive science
society the Bayesian Society and I want
to start the the discussion today by
having you reflect a little bit on your
graduate work you were at UCSD with Dave
Roman heart and and others in the mid
80s at maybe the second Renaissance of
the artificial intelligence area working
in parallel in distributed systems I
still have my two volumes of the PDP
books with the where's that three and a
half inch floppy disks and in the back
can you say a little bit about maybe the
intellectual environment that at the
time this field was really nascent as
well as how its
sort of some of your subsequent thinking
about problems of intelligence and
computation sure first of all it's a
pleasure to be here I've known Susan for
a number of years it's I've been giving
lots of interviews the last few years as
the interest in the field is picked up
it's the first time I've given an
interview to someone who probably knows
more than I know about half of the
topics we're going to be talking about
usually you have to be explaining things
yeah so I've moved around a lot in my my
life and it's really not it's not
directed it's kind of partly random walk
and it's just because of curiosity and
also feeling that not any one person or
any one field has got all the answers
and it's by synthesizing various
people's perspectives and ideas and I
just I was thinking about this earlier
how I might explain that so one of my
friends Jana Khan refers to me as the
Miles Davis of machine learning not the
machine Michael Jordan because he was an
example son who moved throughout his
career just trying new things and
another anecdote was when I was a kid my
my grandparents took me to Europe for
the first time and we went to Sweden and
I loved it and at some point apparently
I was lost least they thought I was lost
they couldn't find me for half a day and
if I did they found me I was with a
bunch of Swedish children cuz I decided
I'd become Swedish because they're just
that I should just do one thing in my
life I should become a Swedish child so
uh so I think that I was at first of all
I had a bad American education and so I
was kind of lucky that I arrived at age
20 I had I knew nothing and so I could
sort of make my own ideas about what to
work on and I had I think most people
that have that age read some philosophy
and found that interesting and I was
lucky enough to be in an era where there
had been analytic philosophy so Bertrand
Russell had written an autobiography and
very presciently he was talking about
the mind and the scientific perspective
on it and how logic and mathematics and
all rose out of the mind and just felt
right to me that there was something
deep about that and he had did it with
kind of a sense of humor and a feeling
that there was something new could
happen in this area so that helped
influence me
and then just buy okra what was
available to me I was a program at San
Diego and it was largely because of
experimental psychology that I found my
first interest
I remember work by people like Roger
Shepard where you talk about mental
rotation and and just the idea you could
probe into a system that was very very
complicated and still glean things about
it from the outside was was fascinating
I was just impressed by the skills of
people able to do that I think
psychology that was just so so hard
we're probing into a massively complex
system there's nothing else like it even
think about the economic system of New
York City it's nothing like the
composite the brain and think about
probing that from you know the from the
atmosphere while you're looking at the
lights or the emissions it's kind of
where we're at so I still feel that that
is the field of the future over the next
several hundred years
I think it'll take that long to start to
really get insights into it and since I
have it unfortunately a short lifetime I
thought I'd better move on before to
move to faster moving fields and I think
kind of luckily as part of that I'd also
studied some statistics cuz you had to
analyze your data and I started to
appreciate not just the use of
statistics and calculated values and do
an analysis variance but the three
hundred-year-old tradition of
inferential thinking that was embodied
and the ideas and were were those
principles coming from it what do they
mean and surely that has something to do
with how humans approach the world so I
was already thinking that what's most
about humans is their ability to
abstract something about the world and
then their ability to deal with all the
uncertainty and to make plans and that
sort of thing so I was sort of less
interested in the low levels um you know
perception emotion processing even
though I did some work on it it just
didn't feel like where my heart was
gonna be so Dave Rummel hard I'm glad
you mentioned him was my first real
advisor in life he was a brilliant man
genial really died young unfortunately
but he set the stage for much of the
work that's going on now and he also I
don't think would be happy with just a
narrow perspective he he really wanted
to think broadly about all the tools and
all the ways of thinking and I really
got that perspective um so he when I
first arrived there was interested in
somatic networks and semantics of
natural language and perception
and I continue to think those are some
of the you know the real problems
perception and abstraction and then how
do you think about semantics I don't
think we're there yet I don't think we
understand them we're very very
primitive in our understanding of those
so then he turned into neural nets and I
and you know back propagation is this
this famous algorithm although it's sort
of really just the chain rule and it's
kind of it's got a control theory side
to it and all that and it's it's it's
reinvented thousands of times but he
really was the person in that neural net
field who kind of worked on it for you
know he reinvented it for but for a
couple of years that was his main focus
his office was right next to him and it
he come in everyday telling me about the
cool new aspects of the what he was
trying to do it he finally got the
algorithm and he tried it out on all the
Minsky Patrick problems and it really
did those and he was super excited about
it so his excitement his intellectual
breadth and his blend of it there was no
disciplinary boundaries for Dave
experimental psychology linguistics
mathematics statistics was all fair game
for his actual adventure so I've taken
away some of that and you talked about
descending into fields and then sucking
up information from from them and and
growing but you also influence all all
those fields and when I look back out at
your early work your thesis was on
learning representations for sequential
performance essentially using recurrent
neural networks for some simple
cognitive tasks and one of the things
that I remember it may have been one of
your first nips papers was work on
adaptive mixtures of experts and that's
something that we'll come back to it at
the end because I know you have lots of
important perspectives on some of the
limitations of current deep models but
those cover a couple of really important
topics one is looking not just at
snapshots of the world but it's
sequences of behavior and the other is
thinking not about isolated competencies
but multiple experts coming together and
it's sort of amazing as I look back at
this earlier today that that work is
what thirty years old now but it really
foreshadowed some
the things that that we're seeing today
yeah those are so thank you for these
great questions I'm not used to getting
such good notice so yeah I was
interested in sequential performance
because they're neural X of the day
didn't do much sequentiality um it was
all about matrices and factorizations
and so on but I was pianist in the
context of a psychological phenomenon
which was speech and if you looked at
you know we're that's one of the most
important sequential acts we do is to
speak but if you look at in detail you
know all of our articulate errs the
tongue and the lips and the vocal tract
vocal chords and all are actually
staggered and there are asynchronous and
they're doing a lot things in parallel
so the feature vector of the speech
apparatus has all the components working
in parallel nonetheless there's an
overall sequentiality to that and so it
was very much to me how do you model
that how do you conceive of that and I
felt like things like neural nets were
relevant because they were naturally
parallel right if we can imbue them with
a bit of sequentiality we can get the
best of both worlds we could sort of see
a little bit of that so actually that
was what I was interested in and I
didn't really innovate I personally I
don't believe very much in the neural
network sphere at that in that
particular line of work just using sort
of record Nets but noticing that if you
did if you train them at a particular
very sequential way they wanted to fill
in and therefore kind of do the kind of
core tic you lations or the parallelism
that you would see in real data and
again that's kind of Dave really liked
he liked that line of work that the
neural net did something that was not
part of the training data but was a
reasonably good description of something
that was humans were doing the other
line of work I in fact has gone further
for me which is just thinking about
modularity and abstraction but also
thinking about when you have multiple
entities that have to coop cooperate or
compete and it's leading and so my
recent work to kind of much more
economics perspectives and thinking
about huge numbers of entities that have
to work together not just a small
handful like in our mixtures work great
I want to pop from your early days and
and it's interesting because you've come
back to some of these these ideas with
you know several decades of advances in
and data infrastructure but before I do
that I want to just talk a little bit
about some of the fundamental
algorithmic and theoretical advances
you've made you know you work on
variational methods for approximate
inference in graphical models this huge
or Lda paper I think has been cited over
25,000 times that work on spectral
clustering on popularizing algorithms
this has really changed you know the
practice of machine learning and and
statistics in many ways do you have a
gem a gem that has not and one of your
favorite innovations and breakthroughs
is it is not as well recognized as some
of the very popular and widely cited
ones
I'm always the most fun of my most
recent work because the older work is
just seems obvious in this respect and
and probably been obvious in the day but
you know no recent work I I'm actually I
think is gone the farthest it's become
more theoretical over time as the field
it's kind of become more empirical I
think learners needs to be a
complementary more theoretical
perspective and so lots of work on
optimization and sampling relationships
and returning to variational themes so
variational is and I learned about it by
for physics physicists but you know it's
a I love the kind of history of
mathematical ideas and variational
course goes back to variational calculus
and before it it says you turn a problem
into an optimization problem so you
maybe it's just your problems to
integrate or your problem is to write
down a difference equation and you say
well how can I formulate that as a
solution to an optimization problem and
the optimization problem could be in a
space of say probable distribution so
your output can be a distribution but
now you say well that's a solution to an
optimization problem having done so you
get brand-new mathematical perspective
in particular you can perturb the
optimization problem that'll then move
the solution a little bit and the
perturbation can lead you to you know
it's insight but it also can lead you to
do algorithms and and so in you know
there's a variational perspectives on
all sort of things calculating an
eigenvector you know an eigenvector is
ax equals lambda X but it's also
a rail a Rocha you optimize a certain
ratio and that is an eigenvector that's
a variational characterization
eigenvector formula in that way you get
new algorithms and so the physicists
were onto this so we people had borrowed
the idea of mean field methods from
physics into neural nets and so there
was lots of these mean field or
deterministic annealing and I found that
very provocative in so started reading
in deeper and and as often was the case
they had had twenty years of history and
had pushed that much further and they
started to call that variational methods
and you know so we borrowed the I think
the broader perspective and then brought
that into contact with graphical models
they mainly were studying a you know
lattices and physics kind of things and
so we said well there's an opportunity
to take those same kind of ideas and
bring them into the much more structure
role of graphical models and particular
directed graphs so conditional
probabilities rather than you know just
field models so in some level it was
just kind of explorations in set of
ideas that hadn't quite been brought
together and then you know e/m ideas
also there hadn't been much work on
doing them with graphical model
variational kind of things and so but
that still goes forward to this day that
line of work I'm actually still feel
it's very very incomplete there's hardly
any theory on it there's finally there's
finally starting to be a little more
innovation algorithmically again it's
picking up again but it you know these
things are really long-term projects for
not just me but for the whole community
you've been doing some work recently on
non convex optimization
yeah can you talk a little bit about
that because a lot of the functions
clearly that we're trying to optimize
especially in deep models well not just
deep models um so you know all kinds of
phased retrieval models all kinds of
combinatorial models a lot of them are
non convex they have a single global
optimum some of them so they seem simple
but they have all these saddle points
and the the the neural nets and all I
think that the one of the key problems
is they have lots of lots of saddle
points I don't think this was
appreciated least in my era back when I
was learning about neural nets it was
all about the globe the local optima
that you'd fall into and the simulated
annealing and ways to get out of that
and I think it's in the last five years
or so that it's been realized well if
there are a few local minimum or even a
whole lot there's could be even more
saddle points and what'll happen and has
it high dementia just get stuck next to
those saddle points for an indeterminate
amount of time and it could EB even you
know scale badly in dimensions so that
if in bigger and bigger problems you'll
spend more time around the saddle points
and you won't know that because we're in
a saddle point you just feel the
learning the learning curve is sort of
flattened out you think you're done but
you really used to have yet to escape
find that direction of escape so let me
mention she Jen who's a student with me
working at Berkeley he's real leader in
this area of saddle point avoidance and
escape and there's a sequence of papers
where she is the lead author that really
dig into this and try to get not just
rates of convergence but dimension
dependence so as alluding to the kind of
propriety in the theoretical work I
think this is it's not just me but the
rest of our field has gotten very good
at not just asymptotic rates but
actually finance sample rates and then
beyond that the constant has dimension
dependence and we're getting the
constants we're getting that sort of the
dimension dependence and so that's a
it's a theory that becomes extremely
interesting mathematically but also very
relevant to practice and gives this
field you know a lot of connections that
didn't exist five or ten years ago so
saddle points are interesting if you
want to avoid them and indeed there's
lots of non convex optimization problems
true but there's also interesting if you
take the game traits perspective or
multiple agents where you don't want to
avoid saddle points you want to find the
saddle points because the Salif ones are
the Nash equilibria or the other kind of
equilibria and so that's an emerging
area that I'm working on with students
in my groups there is a little there is
there is a literature about how to go
towards South points but as is often the
case it's incomplete literature it
didn't face the kind of modern
constraints that we have in a particular
if you create saddle points that are
Nash equilibria you'll probably create
lots of other saddle points that you
don't want to hit just cuz that's how
mathematics tends to work so there's
great open problems there's but and then
if you go to the large-scale versions of
these things where you have not just two
agents or ten but you've got hundreds of
thousands it's gonna be very very
interesting challenging so that's one
aspect of the economics perspective
meets algorithms that I'm very
interested in
great thank you it's right not to talk
about a couple of other topics so one is
you know in the last decade or so we've
seen just dramatic advances in the
capabilities of computational systems to
do things like understand speech to
understand aspects of vision label
objects generate captions to do some
aspects of language understanding
particularly the work in machine
translation I think has been really
beyond my expectations some work in
robotic control and many of these
innovations have fueled I think things
that neither of us would have expected
ten or fifteen years ago the fact that
you can do real-time analysis of voice
on phones in noisy environments and get
it right a startling proportion of the
time you know the fact that in machine
translation you can translate from one
language to another in near real-time
these accomplishments have fueled a
variety of interesting new computational
capabilities yet they have a set of very
isolated competencies and you recently
published I guess it's an op-ed piece or
a thought piece in medium on artificial
intelligence the revolution that hasn't
happened yet that generated a lot of
buzz can can you reflect on you know the
fact that there have been amazing
advantages advances yet we're miles and
miles and miles away from thinking about
intelligence and in the same way that
that you see in humans or more
interestingly interacting sets of humans
and computational elements great
question again so there's a lot of
issues there that need to be untangled
and so I'm not try not to speak too long
but in my op-ed tries to untangle I
think that everyone has lumped too much
into the phrase AI and I one of my the
phrases I was proud about the op-ed was
that people are using AI is an
intellectual wild card
that when they don't understand what's
happening in or understand how to solve
it they say you know AI will do it or
that's an AI problem or whatever most of
these systems are pattern recognition
systems and that's great there are lots
of patterns in the world and these
things that are pretty good if you have
especially lots of labels that help you
find those patterns I first of all don't
think that's the whole class problems
I'm interested in or many of us should
be interested in I think that creating
systems that serve humans and help us
make our lives safer more interesting do
this at scale make us able to interact
with other humans in the world better
very few of those have a lot to do with
creating artificial humans with speech
language vision problems they have to do
with all kinds of decision making at
scale they have to do with problems that
none of us evolved to solve that our
human diligence isn't particularly good
at and whereas you know good
decision-making inferential principles
are gonna be needed to build such
systems if you think of domains like
Commerce or healthcare or finance or you
know etc there's just crying out for
here's data here's utilities of large
numbers of players how do I create
something that will work for people so I
don't think that working on what I
called in that article human imitative
AI the kind of classical you know
aspiration which is still an aspiration
I don't think it's necessary for it's
efficient for working on a lot of these
broader challenges so lumping them all
together I think is a mistake
it's the the biggest progress has been
made energy while you're talking about
vision and speech natural language and
so on
but the algorithms that are used for
that are not necessary the ones are
going to work for trying to make a
hundred thousand decisions at scale so
mccann fortunate to think that those are
the mainly the main class of problems
that industry should be focusing on
there's a larger class of problems they
should be focusing on now also I do need
to push back idea said the word speech
understanding and language understanding
and intelligence maybe even I'll come up
I don't think these systems and with all
due respect for my college originals
areas are doing much speech
understanding right they're transcribing
a waveform into lexical items right very
impressively with lots of noise and all
that but they don't understand anything
about the speech okay moreover the
natural language translation systems are
not understanding the language at all
they are taking in a French sentence and
basically they are mapping it that
string to an English string alright and
there's no there's no understanding
between here and there now when we look
at the outputs of these kind of things
in the errors and the kind of things
they could do we as humans were able to
sort of read into them say wow it seemed
to understand something well no there
was a statistical thing that it picked
up on and that's not all it is that's
not and so our ability to understand
what's happening the world to abstract
in particular we are miraculous
abstractors and neural nets do a little
bit of abstraction in their feature
finding but they don't think about the
kind of high level you know multifaceted
complex abstraction humans I mean to be
fair a lot of human capabilities
especially perceptual capabilities are
based on statistical regularities of the
world well they could be based on that
we don't know if they are I mean so
think about a you know a squirrel ie to
talk about this in the op-ed too but you
know a squirrel is an amazing perceptual
motor system it hops among the trees in
ways that you know we can even hardly
imagine right so it's doing somehow its
brain as evolved or maybe learned but
probably not learned a lot probably a
lot of you know evolution came into
making that squirrel so good so it's
able to do things that we can hardly
fathom that our neural nets or maybe you
start you know approach at the end of
our lifetimes will they be able to see a
large squirrels I would hesitate though
to say a squirrel has a lot of
intelligence building such as a squirrel
like system would require a vast amount
of intelligence or even intelligence but
I hesitate to say that that system is
going to be one that embodies what I
would recognize is intelligence or
understanding of the world or being able
to abstract about it and you know I
think squirrels I don't want to limit
what squirrels could do they can pry do
some problem solving and annoy us with
their abilities
regarde you know but really so if you
haven't seen Doug Hofstadter first thing
on he had an op ed as well around the
same time I wrote mine on the
shallowness of google translate and i
think he does a pretty good job of
saying if you don't have any semantics
at all you're just not gonna really be
able to solve natural language
translation and so you get a sense that
people think well we got went from 80%
to you know 90 to 95 of course we're
gonna be to 99.9 Sood and just more
hardware and more data will do it and
that just is not true in a domain where
it really requires a rich understanding
of the world around us to really do it I
mean I think it's really clear that
there are huge limitations to the the
competencies that current systems have
can and that to get to the next level we
need to think more broadly about systems
that have sort of perceptual level
recognition capabilities as well as more
symbolic deductive reasoning well they
may be some well maybe doctor they may
not they're abstraction is a word that
doesn't have to be you know the you know
the idea that we're having an interview
that's an abstraction of what is
happening with all the pixels and all
the sound waves in the room right now
and it's not a low-low abstraction it's
quite a high level there's many many
kinds of interviews and many many kinds
of situations that all of us humans
really understand that kind of thing I
also noticed on the last time I came
here to Microsoft I was participating an
event called a disruptive technology
review all right and I know what
disruption means but it now has all
kinds of other meanings that people have
kind of associate with it's become a
good thing first of all and all of us
understand that and disruptive
technology really can be parsed in two
ways it could be a disruptive technology
review we're reviewing the disruptive
technology or it could be a disruptive
technology to review all right and we
all get that and it's interesting even
funny and amusing you probably don't
think about it you probably picked one
of those too but they're both there
our computers are very very far from the
ability to understand things at that in
that FX sense and make and have humor
about them and use them in creative ways
and do that not just for the words
disruptive a technology but for about
every other word that we can think of
even the word you know saying that bad
is
good and stuff like that as humans
really really are flexible with it the
ability to use that and that's not even
talking about how we interact with the
real world and the abstractions that are
involved there so you know these aren't
problems that one can't work on and you
know it's just decades and it's not that
we get enough big datasets and enough
hardware and we get it I just think
there's a little night there's a lot of
naivete about that it my colleagues who
work on those problems in natural
language don't have that naive day but
for the most part but a lot of the PR
agents for sort of the companies that
are doing this do have that ETA and
that's being spread out too far into the
community can you say do you have any
reflections on what's needed to get to
the to some of the competencies that
well I can give my own I mean there's
just a huge number in fact in some of my
talks they give a long list of
challenges for kind of you know it's not
just that you need symbols you need all
sorts of other things but I mean I I
think I'm gonna try to avoid your
question just because I'm not I'd you
know I dabble in NLP but you know
certainly you know relations and
certainly a minimal amount of kind of
first-order kind of things certainly the
ability to deal with hierarchies and the
ability to deal with abstractions at
various levels but I I think we don't
really know what we really need yet so I
think it's kind of like someone who was
able to you know the first people who
had gunpowder and could kind of build a
very minimal rocket and then could dream
about going to the moon someday right
and we did go the moon someday but there
was a whole lot of other new concepts
that had to be invented to actually get
there all the way to the moon and so I
think we're leaving lots of problems for
the younger generation and even if a
neural net could court of taker you know
it can do like Arabic to English
translation at 99% which I don't believe
that's going to happen it's gonna really
at that point be such a huge black box
this is not you know healthy for us to
turn that over the next generation say
here we're done we did natural language
translation they're not gonna be very
happy about that and they shouldn't be
so let me just add one more point I
don't want to come across as negative
about this I don't I I mean this is a
great fact that that you know notes are
an amazingly good
recognition class versus amande that
also means you can use these for
real-world problems so the fact that we
have you know okay but not particularly
good translation means that I could
probably now take a device I could speak
into it and out would come bad Mandarin
and if where I can walk around in China
and I can aim it or actually I could
have never had and that's good for me
it's good for society it's good for
humans that things like that can be done
alright but but it tends to lead in
people's minds way further than that
they think well we've almost got natural
translation done buh-buh-buh-buh VARs
that lead to and the fact is well we're
not even close to really we're like 1
percent of the really be able to do like
a human being can do like a Shakespeare
can write Shakespeare but even like my
11 year old can interact with his world
using natural language could interact
with their world in ways that you know
many of our current systems cancer can't
do I wanted to read you a quote from
your the AI though I feel like I'm
selling at a quarter
five years ago Mike you said this and
now you're saying this just as humans
built buildings and bridges before there
was civil engineering humans are
processing with the building of societal
scale inference and decision-making
systems that involve machines humans in
the environment just as early building
and bridges sometimes fall to the ground
fell to the ground in unforeseen and
ways with tragic consequences many of
our early societal scale inference and
decision-making systems are already
exposing serious conceptual flaws you
can do a little bit of that in your
previous comment but this really focuses
on these larger systems issues and
systems ways of thinking yeah
can you you comment on some of that you
know fragility how we're setting up
people to think about what's what's
possible and and really what steps we
need to take to to make progress in some
of these areas yeah so I really
attempted in this op-ed to give
engineering the due respect that it
needs in Germany is not just a bunch of
nerds playing around with wires and the
engineering is really thinking about how
to make the world a better place and how
to make it a little more predictable a
little more interesting and so on so I
have great respect for people who did
civil engineering Chemical Engineering
and past generations by my father was a
chemical engineer and they started with
kind of chemical principles that you
blend these test tubes together and out
comes something and they went from there
all the way to be able to put this
together in a factory and they needed a
huge raft of principles to do that not
just the basic chemistry but all kinds
of mechanical things and all kinds of
you know arrange about as I know very
little about that took decades to
develop and so I think that that's the
kind of thing that we're talking about
here and but it's even a grander thing
we're talking about bringing humans into
it in a very central way and their
utilities and their desires in the
conflicts or the cooperation that's
involved there and we're talking about
data and so on so when you start to do
that you realize it's gonna be very much
decades it's not going to emerge AI is
not gonna happen in five years here or
and and and who cares if we get you know
systems that look like humans it's
really about these systems and so in my
op it I try to kind of come up with very
simple examples of problems you might
think are already easily solved or
whatever but aren't so provenance so you
know database people are interested in a
piece of data not just the piece of data
itself but where it came from some
metadata around it you know who did it
when did was it done and all that and
that can be used helpfully in you know
various database systems to make sure
something does go here and and
consistent and so on it's much much
worse when you think about learning
systems and data analysis and
predictions and decisions so I used an
example of medical data had that yeah
you know at anytime you sit down in
front of a doctor they're good at you're
gonna think well they've got some weird
symptoms here if I you ever seen
anything like that
and hopefully they read all the medical
literature so they know all the data but
maybe they don't right but there's
always not gonna be a particularly good
match between what they see in you and
your symptoms and and others and maybe
ideally there's a really good match but
in general what you're doing is you're
taking some somewhat ill-formed ad hoc
set of observations that were collected
at a different
in a different time in a different
situation in different context and
you're making a judgment about how
relevant they are to the current
situation it's never gonna be the case
that the current situation just fits
exactly the data you've collected
yesterday for that particular purpose
all right so being able to assess the
relevance
oh that data is actually irrelevant
therefore I do not the provenance of
that data is is not relevant to the
situation
therefore I cut off my neural net I do
not let it make the inference that it
seems like it wants to make right and I
need to have my error bars reflect that
relevance calculation moreover it's
often to be the case that something some
data was gathered at some place in time
and it fit through many pathways and it
comes in and to us it looks like a bunch
of independent evidence and we say well
I'm seeing five thousand you know people
were saying this thing and it was just
that someone created the the the rumor
back back when so you know our political
world is full of this our journalistic
world is full of this and a lot of false
positives are happening people still
don't understand much about false
discovery rate that your goal and life
shouldn't be to make accuracy high it
should make that relative to the
discoveries your measure there's there's
a denominator and a numerator there our
current systems that do neural nets and
all that are doing very very little with
uncertainty they're not they're very new
and very little with what-if questions
they're doing very little with the kind
of things you need to happen real
intelligent the system even if it's not
a super intelligence do in fact they're
doing essentially nothing with
uncertainty and and so huge gap so how
that's kind of the engineering
discipline needs to emerge how you know
it's not enough just to know how to put
together basic ingredients to build up a
pattern recognition system if that
pattern of justice system takes in the
symptoms of me in the doctor's office
and says you need a heart operation I'm
gonna say what's your error bar on that
are you sure it's at 90 to 99 percent
sure or whatever where's that error bar
coming from
did you know a certain fact about my
family do you know that what I you know
other facts about me could me think
about this what if expert would it could
we get some more data and so on those
are the things we just can't do it all
but forget even you know that we can't
mimic what a five-year-old can do in
language and all that we can't do those
kind of competencies you know about
Providence about multiple
in making about uncertainty about and so
on and I just don't see enough people
talking about this stuff
so you're taking a very system's level
approach to you know to thinking about
this interesting new set of emerging
environments that blend human
computation and machine computation what
do you think the the right frameworks
for for thinking about that or I mean
there's clearly a notion of abstraction
there are you talked about provenance
the fact that we make multiple decisions
not isolated decisions the fact that the
world is not iid by any stretch of the
imagination in fact that's probably the
exception rather than the rule how do
you start thinking from either a
theoretical or an engineering
perspective about providing some of
those tools I know you have working yeah
well so I think we're gonna need a kind
of a Newcomb Agora off to emerge or a
new terrine or whatever to really really
break open new things and whoever she is
it's gonna be great I can't wait but the
best I can do in my lifetime at least is
as I alluded to earlier is to not just
look within one discipline not just
think that one's one one technique and
one way of thinking is the right answer
so I do believe that there the vast
scope of inferential thinking of
thinking about what's out in the real
world and how to infer that from the
limited data I see including all the
sampling patterns that might have gone
into it the bias is it might have arise
those are ideas that come from 300 years
of Statistics and it always pains me
when I see people that just do were more
narrowly in the machine learning world
say well here's a new problem we've not
talked about fairness before or bias
well yes people have so if you take the
vast scope of inferential thinking and
you put that together with the slightly
s vast but amazing you know
computational era the last hundred years
and kind of the you know the signal
processing control theory perspectives
it's already some amazing an electoral
challenges to try to bring those
together once you do you get real power
you can have systems that can actually
say you know in some with some certain
amount of companies or resources I can
give you answers that are trusted belen
a compeition sense but also I've got
Berzin a visual now to me I actually
think in the last mile assed 15 years of
my career my last third let's say I'm
gonna do my best to bring economic
principles to bear with these others as
well so um you know I do think if you
make one decision or a sequence decision
that's kind of classical AI and
statistics but if you have to make your
system has to make a hundred thousand
decisions simultaneously no human being
has to do that so we didn't evolve to do
it but our systems are got to do that
and so you need a new kind of thinking
and so economic thinking is about not
about a single person and their thinking
style
it's about large collections not just to
people but of other entities and there
has been work where was algorithmic game
theory there's econometrics where these
fields have been brought together but
it's as usual in very limited ways so I
do I believe if you bring organizational
thinking and and together with with
inferential and computational already
the challenges are immense and that's
what we need to face a lot of problems
of course think you're not done there's
there's you know psychological and
social and ethical etc etc but still
just this hardcore of a building systems
that are economically reasonable and the
way they set up in settings among
multiple components of the system and
that are able to integrate humans that
humans can have transparency into them
and and that they have since the skull
solidity behind them not just in there's
p-values or error bars but there's been
a appropriate sampling pattern there's
been a design there's a robust and then
that these things will work over time
like the provenance that she doesn't
come up if you're looking at one time
slice right Providence comes up because
the data is out of date for me it was
collected last year in a different City
and all that so
gosh why just talking about it you see
what both excited but also I think it's
daunting and and I think that we have a
little bit too much hysteria about how
great everything is we're we're done I
think the younger people will maybe get
this know this is the beginning it's not
a gold rush it's the start of chemical
engineering but you know to the factor
to the power 10 and it'll take decades
and you engage roll up your sleeves and
try to make sure that we don't over hype
and we don't get people going crazy
about things like our you know
superhuman intelligence which is not
going to happen
what machines and humans are
complementary or complementary skills
and I think you know it as simple or
simpler level you're talking about sort
of massive systems and massive scales
and hundreds of thousands of
interoperating parts but that's the real
world we live in already right now I
mean think about transportation systems
right that you know all these cars are
going around there all these limited
resources called highways and there's
danger and there's issues and so if you
put that into I mean you know the Bur
and DD and already do a limited amount
of this but you can easily create
congestion you can create troubles if
you don't kind of think about the
lengths set of decisions that a group of
people have to make and and the system
has to do that quote unquote and that's
going to be partly human and partly
there's a very interesting world of I
think hybrid computation systems that we
don't know a lot about the principles
and those were those systems are now
situated in a real world they're not
just in a simulated world or in a
laboratory and so I think you know as
you point out there are just immense
challenges but but also immense
opportunities let me ask you one one
last question I you've had an amazing
set of students over the last 20 or 30
years I wrote some of the yoshua bengio
David Bly Emily Fox Subin Guerra mati
Thomas Hoffman
Tommy yoga Percy Lang marina Malay
Andrew Inge so tender saying Alice Jiang
more recently we talked I guess one of
your current students aja Wilson is
joining the New York New England lab I
guess Lester Mackey is already there
Lester Mackey is already there right
and Peter boudic is already here in
Redmond what advice do you have for the
young students getting involved in in
computer science machine learning what
what should they study how should they
get out of in many ways there at the rat
race of climbing up the leaderboard and
isolated problems you know I don't have
any secrets about I just really every
year I'm amazed by how smart the
these people are and how enthusiastic
and entrepreneurial and progressive
minded they are and I get very very
inspired by that and I just try to look
with each person kind of look at who
they are as an individual and what what
they've got and what they're missing and
get them to realize it's like five or
six years to kind of you know realize
what they have inside of themselves and
I tend to encourage them don't be in a
rush again this is not a gold rush is
not your opportunity to make money
there's not your opportunity to be
famous or whatever it's your opportunity
to become a guru it's your opportunity
to study and to actually say something
meaningful and deep and I'll just say
what everybody else is saying and I try
to get ahead of everybody but just you
know I head off I often tell them how
off an orthogonal direction you see
everybody going that way appreciate why
they're doing it and all that but
appreciate also what they're leaving and
missing and then go orthogonal and then
you can take your own time and you can
do it at your own pace and you can have
a lot of comfort with eventually when
you start to say things so a lot of
those great students who who really have
done some great things they have
published a small handful of papers not
all of them are some counter-examples
who published a way more than they
should have but a few of them published
a small handful of papers but they were
deep papers and it was a pleasure to be
able to write about how they really
solved a big challenge
you know aja Wilson you know Lee oppan
of theory you know for continuous
dynamical systems that do optimization
you know Lester Mackey did this amazing
work on Stein's method you know applied
to matrix concentration even though it
was not at all his everybody he just it
was an orthogonal cut in a space that he
was taking he spent a year to working on
it and something beautiful came out a
handful of those kind of things and
people pay attention oh this is someone
who can actually think in new ways and
help us to move along I guess the other
point I want to make is that I loved all
my students partly cuz how great their
minds were just but also how friendly
and fun fun they were to be around so
when I pick students it's kind of a
enthusiasm and love of abstraction of
mathematical ideas of try to understand
deeply but also humility about each one
of our own role in this and how we
being in a social environment and
connecting to each other is the best way
for all this to work and it's fun so
I've had a particularly social group
they've all made friends with each other
and I've made friends with them too and
I feel very connected not just to them
but to you know to a lot of other
researchers out in the world I do travel
around to Europe and China and other
place a lot and I easily find myself
kind of in Greece you know getting
involved in people's lives there and
what they think and what they do because
I think we all are really sharing a lot
of this so I do very much resist the AI
is gonna be done in this country or that
country sort of thing and all its really
about trade and it's really about shared
understanding and share development and
I think that the younger people just get
that and so as long as we kind of
encourage them that you don't have to
give up on that that you can build a
career that is based on you know
sincerity honesty and and study and you
can that their natural strengths come
right out yeah I love the reflections on
this being giving people space to grow
not feeling like they have to publish 10
nips papers in a year doing it as part
of a larger intellectual community when
I think back on the PDP days there was
that sense of energy and excitement and
so I love the those reflections and for
new students in that thinking about how
to get into these areas and
to make progress part of it is to slow
down take a broader perspective and
surround yourself in an environment
where you can share ideas share nascent
ideas and work together to come up to
some great solutions so ya know and
Microsoft is a great I really you know
over the years continue to be amazed by
how stable it's been as a kind of an
intellectual source in the world and I
see Microsoft was kind of returning to
the for right now just to give a little
plug times this summer
and you know I think it's really kind of
watched the space of IT development
throughout the world and it said there's
a role we can play and it's sort of a
almost a senior citizen but you know
Bree trusts back to you how you know IT
interacts with the world I think there's
a that's one of the big agenda items I
think it's being embraced here and I'm
real pleased about that and so the
academic industry relationship I think
is very healthy and Microsoft is kind of
helping lead that as we go I mean for
for us and for the rest of the industry
I think we need to nurture the kind of
students that you and and others are
developing and and do that together it's
there are lots of things that folks
experience in industry that they may or
may not in university so I think it's a
beautiful synergy I agree thanks for
being part of that with us all right
thank you